j'ai une question pour vous est-ce que
ça vous est déjà arrivé de perdre vos
clés juste avant de devoir partir ou de
pas retrouvé un papier jusqu'en vous en
avez besoin de recevoir une mauvaise
nouvelle
jusqu'en il faut pas de sentir un peu
c'était clair qui vous traverse et qui
fait qui prend presque le contrôle de
votre corps de votre esprit et qui fait
perdre un peu la boule de temps en temps
des fois ça fait qu'on s'énerve sur
l'armoire sur le chien de pas d'ordre à
retrouver ses clés
et bien moi ce que j'appelle ça c'est
l'énergie brute parce que en anglais par
exemple émotion ces images in motion ce
mouvement est hissé l'énergie et cette
énergie brute
on peut la maîtriser pour la mettre au
service de sa réussite personnelle
quand je vous parle de réussite
personnelle je vous parle pas de devenir
millionnaires dans les dix années à
venir ou même cette année je parle de ce
jour vous allez vous lever pour aller
travailler sans avoir l'impression
d'aller travailler faire vraiment ce que
vous aimez cette réussite là mais déjà
donc qui je suis ben à 19 ans j'ai pris
une décharge de 15 mille volts pour moi
je me suis endormie comme n'importe quel
soir et en fait je me suis réveillé six
semaines après j'ai eu six semaines de
coma bon pour la faire grève quand je me
suis réveillé on m'a annoncé que j'avais
été amputé des deux bras que j'ai été
brûlé sur 50 % de la surface corporelle
mais rien ne fonctionnait plus mon fois
non plus mes poumons non plus j'étais
mort deux fois fin la liste était très
très longue et je suis resté grosso modo
un an à l'hôpital dont six mois où j'ai
été paralysé le médecin disait souvent
que j'allais par marchés ou des choses
comme ça et puis après j'ai été
transféré dans une clinique où je g
touré a pris et là où on ne prévoyait
trois ans juste à l'hôpital et puis
encore après avec un passage en clinique
je me retrouve en fait après trois ans
et demi devant vous là ce soir
il se trouve que ben j'ai beaucoup
d'activités parce que je suis bête
thérapeute je fais beaucoup de coaching
coach un peu de personnalité du cinéma
français je cite thérapeute avec une
psychologue
j'ai monté trois entreprises je suis
étudiant et je suis auteur et
conférencier
donc voilà pour mon petit cd 1 et donc
vous allez dire comment prendre
justement comment devenir maître de
cette énergie brute et bien on change
dans le monde sait que j'en entends déjà
quelques-uns qui se doit et changer le
monde c'est bien gentil mais pas aussi
facile à faire qu'à dire on oublie en
fait qu'on a cette capacité tous au fond
de nous soit si vous vous rappelez quand
on était tout petit on voyait des formes
dans les nuages ou bien dans les
feuillages des arts dans les montagnes
on s'imagine est tout le temps plein de
choses et en fait on part notre vision
du monde ont créé notre monde et c'est
ça notre pouvoir à nous c'est pour
changer le monde il faut qu'on change
tout d'abord notre vision de celui ci et
donc la premier changement si on veut
justement être capable de devenir maître
de cette énergie brute c'est de
comprendre qu'on est maître de son
destin
c'est quelque chose que moi j'ai mis un
peu de temps à comprendre et il faut
passer de la perspective de spectateurs
à acteurs donc de perspectives de ap un
pardon et quand je vous dis de devenir
maître de son destin
c'est de comprendre qu'on est
responsable en fait de la construction
de son avenir c'est à dire qu'on est
responsable aussi bien de ses échecs que
de ses réussites et plus que de ses
échecs
on est surtout responsable de la
substance qu'on va réussir à en retirer
des apprentissages qu'on va en tirer
parce que un homme qui sera tourné vers
le passé
ce sera un homme qui avancera à reculons
un homme qui tire pas d'apprentissage dé
ses échecs c'est un homme qui tourne en
rond alors qu'un homme qui est capable
d'étirer de la substance de ses échecs
et qui se rend plus forts grâce à ça
c'est un homme qui avancera vers sa
réussite à lui et c'est la première
chose qui est indispensable pour devenir
maître de son destin et devenir maître
de son énergie brute c'est de comprendre
qu' on a le pouvoir de façonner notre
avenir
moi on me voyait tout sauf façonner un
avenir on voyait dans un fauteuil
roulant j'avais un espèce de bras
électriques comme ça qui m'a servi à
m'amuser mais qui ne savaient pas à
grand chose on me disait que j'allais
jamais retrouver de l'autonomie et je
leur ai prouvé le contraire parce que
c'était moi qui ai décidé de devenir
maître de mon destin moi c'était moi qui
allais choisir où j'allais finir la
deuxième chose qu'il faut savoir c'est
que il faut être capable quelque part de
changer point de vue et il
un exemple tout simple pour ça c'est le
mécanisme de mémoire dans le sens où la
mémoire elle se construit sur des
souvenirs et les souvenirs c'est rien
d'autre qu'un choix d'éléments qu'on va
décider de retenir de mémoriser ce qu'on
va accorder plus d'importance à l'un ou
à l'autre et donc en fait on se
construit sur base d'éléments qui sont
fragmentaires parce qu'on oublie
certaines parties on peut pas tout
retenir et c'est ça qui va nous
accompagner pour développer notre vision
du monde est ce que c'est pour autant la
bonne vision et ce qui a qu'une seule
bonne vision non et donc il faut être
capable de changer point de vue pour
être créatifs pour trouver des solutions
à des problèmes où personne n'en trouve
pour être rapide pour atteindre sa
réussite à soi on dit souvent que les
français du sud
ils verront toujours le verre de pastis
sa moitié plein en fait plutôt à moitié
vide parce que leurs huit à eux c'est
qu'on le remplissent la personne qui va
faire attention à sa consommation
d'alcool elle va s'efforcer de le voir à
moitié plein pour pas vouloir leur
remplir trop vite et c'est ça qu'il faut
faire
faut être capable de modeler sa vision
du monde en fonction de l'objectif qu'on
poursuit même même pour l'apéro 2
ensuite il y aura une notion de zone de
confort cette zone de confort qu'on
connaît tous ce qui est un peu reposante
qui est sécurisante et relaxante et
surtout en coup tente en coûte entre
parce que la zone de confort elle a une
dynamique toute particulière c'est à
dire qu'elle est en perpétuel mouvement
soit elle grandit soit elles rapetissent
rapt ici jusqu'à disparaître
je vous explique pourquoi qu'on sort de
sa zone de confort on l'agrandît on
découvre de nouvelles choses on découvre
de nouvelles personnes on va donc de
nouveau contexte et donc on est à l'aise
à de plus grandes occasions différentes
occasions là où on l'était pas avant
mais si on reste en permanence dans sa
zone de confort on perd petit à petit
goût de cette zone de confort tout ce
qu'on a devient la norme
je laisse moi je l'expérimenté de
manière très frappante je venais j'ai
beaucoup voyagé dans ma jeunesse parce
que j'ai eu une jeunesse un peu
particulière et je suis arrivé en suisse
il ya pas longtemps et quand je suis
arrivé là bas les gens se rendaient pas
compte de la beauté du lac et moi
c'était quelque chose qui m'a halluciné
mois voir le mont blanc c'était un truc
énorme
l'avez jamais vu jamais je voyais que
les immeubles en face de moi les gens
s'habituent
et c'est pour ça elle raft ici jusqu'à
disparaître donc il faut être capable de
sortir de temps en temps de cette zone
de confort et quand on sort de cette
zone de confort il faut pas s'imposer de
limites
mon contexte m'a imposé énormément de
les médecins il voulait éviter des
frustrations ça partait d'une bonne
intention
les infirmières aussi mais il m'a posé
des limites en permanence et quand on
imposait une limite moi je voyais ça
comme un challenge
je me disais ok on pose une limite moi
je vais prouver je suis plus fort que la
limite parce que quelque part passer sa
limite c'est vivre une réussite une vais
vivre une réussite qu'on soit contre son
contexte
parce que souvent les et les limites
elles sont surtout ce autant infligées
sont des excuses qu'on trouve les
excuses quelques parts sont des petits
mensonges que notre conscience et nous
raconte gentiment pour pas qu'on se
sente trop coupable quand on fait parce
qu'on est censé faire ou ce qu'on veut
faire
donc il faut être capable d'exploser ses
limites de les détruire et d'aller voir
ailleurs pour vivre cette réussite qui
nous attend juste de l'autre côté cette
petite victoire qu'on aura envers nous
mêmes vous allez me dire c'est bien joli
c'est vrai que les limites sont souvent
imposés en premier par nous mêmes
et sinon par notre contexte mais souvent
la limite et leur lit à une notion de
peur ben changeons justement de points
de vue sur la peur moi la peur elle est
devenue une amie parce qu'elle est là
pour m'indiquer justement l'importance
de la chose que je m'apprête à faire et
surtout elle est là de nouveau pour
m'indiquer que j'aurai une victoire à
fêter juste après on va prendre un
exemple tout simple
j'étais à la clinique et j'avais encore
d'ailleurs on le voit un peu sur cette
photo j'avais encore de tuyaux qui
arrivaient directement dans mon cou
c'était dans l'aorte directement et les
médecins avaient été formel c'était
interdit pour moi de faire du ski il ya
un ami à moi qui m'a proposé viens on va
quand même faire du ski on sort un petit
coup et bon j'ai jamais suivi vraiment
ce que les médecins me disais donc
j'allais pas commencer à ce moment là
donc évidemment j'ai répondu vas y viens
on y va mais au moment où j'ai répondu
oui j'ai commencé à sentir que j'étais
plus très très à l'aise dans mes baskets
parce que tout le discours des médecins
aux filles au final ça rentre quand même
en tête et puis on commence à se poser
des questions on a ce petit discours
interne toutes les appréhensions qu'on
peut avoir et ça
continuez continuez jusqu'au moment où
on a pris le télésiège parce
qu'évidemment pour tester les skis mais
j'avais aucune autre possibilité que de
monter en haut de la piste et puis
d'essayer de la descendre jeudi ria pas
d'entre deux chats pas du tout comment
mon équilibre allait fonctionner à cette
occasion je savais rien du tout et en
arrivant en haut de la piste je me suis
rendu compte d'une chose surmonter sa
peur souvent on en fait un foin pas
possible on en fait une montagne mais
quand on y réfléchit c'est une fraction
de seconde même pas une fraction de
seconde c'est le décalage de l'horloge
atomique
voilà elles elles peuvent le mesurer
mais nous on peut pas mais c'est une
fraction de seconde et de l'autre côté
de nouveau c'est une victoire c'est une
réussite
et si on pouvait voir les choses comme
ça la peur serait plus une peur la peur
se seraient une amie on serait content
de la rencontrer est ce que ça veut dire
qu'on va faire quelque chose de très
important pour nous en fonction de la
quantité de peur qu'on va expérimenter
et ça veut dire que juste après on aura
une victoire comme quand on pète les
limites je peux prendre un exemple vous
êtes sous votre couette tranquille
vous avez pris la décision de vous
remettre en forme ou de reprendre le
sport l'été arrive donc on a envie de
perdre quelques kilos près de biens en
maillot de bain et on se dit tous les
matins je vais courir et ce matin il
pleut il fait moche je suis fatigué je
suis un peu sorti la veille j'ai un peu
le regard embrumé j'ai un peu mal à la
tête j'ai pas envie mais là déjà la zone
de confort c'est quoi c'est le lit et la
limite c'est quoi si j'ai pas envie
d'être mouillés et j'ai pas envie
d'avoir froid et j'ai pas envie de me
lever
mais bon j'ai envie de rien à part de
rester là et justement détruire cette
limite et prouver que vous êtes plus
fort que l'appli vous êtes capable de
sortir de cette zone de confort pour
vous mettre en un confort ça vous donne
une force ça vous donner la force que
vous n'êtes plus fort que votre vie vous
êtes plus fort que l'inconfort vous est
plus fort que la pluie et la prochaine
fois ce sera même plus une question vous
verrez qu'il pleut dehors mais vous
aurez déjà trouvé toutes des manières
d'apprécier ses plus de passer au dessus
de faire différemment mais vous ferez
quand même ce que vous vous étiez fixé
de faire et c'est là que j'ai dit que ça
vous amène à votre réussite personnelle
c'est dans le sens où quand on arrive à
faire tout ça on arrive à se fixer un
objectif à soi qui nous parlent vraiment
peu importe à quel point c'est fou mais
on arrive à le faire et on arrive à le
poursuivre jusqu'au bout
alors s'il vous plaît quand vous
déciderez d'engendrer la machine pour
aller justement cherché cette réussite
personnelle
rappelez vous d'une chose y a personne
d'autre que vous pour 37 énergie n ya
personne d'autre que vous pourrez
explosé détruire les limites pour aller
voir ce qu'il ya de l'autre côté il ya
personne d'autre que vous pour façonner
cette énergie et la modeler pour qu'elle
vous emmène là où vous avez envie
d'aller et à personne d'autre que vous
pour transformer la peur en un moteur
qui vous mènera encore plus vite à cette
victoire qui vous attend juste de
l'autre côté de cette petite fraction de
seconde merci beaucoup
et pour finir j'ai encore une dernière
petite vidéo juste pour vous dire que
rien n'est impossible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]